Гонка озброєнь між Росією і Заходом розгортається на тлі конфлікту в Україні.
При цьому видатки на озброєння самої України минулоріч скоротилися через інфляцію.
Хоча Київ витратив на зброю на 10% більше у 2017 році, ніж в 2016-му,
по факту це лише 3,4 відсотка ВВП, тоді як у 2016 році це були чотири відсотки.
У світовому ж рейтингу продажу зброї Укроборонпром опустився з 79 на 81 місце.
Такі дані Стокгольмського інституту проблем миру СІПРІ.
Беззаперечним лідером з продажу озброєння залишаються США.
Початок листопада: американську зброю тестують на маневрах НАТО.
Постачання зброї союзникам і в 2017 році забезпечило Сполученим Штатам
місце найбільшого в світі виробника зброї.
США залишаються найбільшим виробником зброї із великим відривом.
Є багато американських фірм, які на чолі рейтингу.
СІПРІ з 2002 року складає рейтинг сотні найбільших компаній,
що виробляють та продають озброєння.
Західні фірми у ньому знову домінують.
57% зброї припадає на США. Друге місце зазвичай посідала Великобританія.
У 2017 році її вперше обігнала Росія.
Україна ж увійшла до переліку країн,
що позначені як "інші", продаж озброєння яких не перевищив одного відсотка.
Росія постійно підвищувала свої видатки на озброєння з 2008 по 2017 роки,
щоб модернізувати свої збройні сили.
Російські компанії виграли від цього. Росія майже все закуповує у власних фірм.
Нещодавно держсекретар США Майк Помпео
розкритикував розробку і випробування Росією нової крилатої ракети.
Москва, за його словами, порушує Договір про ліквідацію ракет середньої та малої дальності.
Якщо Росія не повернеться до повного дотримання договору,
ми знімемо з себе відповідні зобов'язання протягом шістдесяти днів.
Наші дані про те, як ці випробування відбувалися, говорять про зворотне.
Вона була випробувана на дозволену договором дальність.
Під питанням - один з найважливіших договорів про роззброєння часів кінця "холодної війни".
Утім модернізація російської армії - лише один з елементів сучасної гонки озброєнь.
Є напруга, навіть конфлікт між Сходом і Заходом з 2014-го року.
З іншого боку планети є Китай, який збільшує свої військові потужності на тлі конфронтації зі США,
з Японією і кількома іншими азійськими країнами.
Звісно, вони усі реагують на дії один одного та збільшують видатки на зброю.
Нове дослідження показало, світ іще на крок віддалився від миру.